لذلك بدأت أشعر
بعدم الارتياح أكثر فأكثر بشأن
موقف Twitter ، يبدو أن هناك شيئًا خاطئًا بشأن
النظام الأساسي ، يبدو أن محادثاتي مع
مجلس الإدارة والإدارة تؤكد
حدسي حول ذلك عندما وصلت إلى هناك
وفجأة أصبحت تملكه وكل شيء
البيانات الموجودة على الخدمة ملك لك وما
يخص الأشخاص من
وجهة نظري ولكن نعم ولكن يمكنك أن ترى ما
هي ويمكنك أن ترى ما كانوا
يفعلونه ويمكنك أن ترى من كان يعمل
هناك الذي صدمت له  اكتشف
أن وكالات إنتل المختلفة كانت
تؤثر على عملياتها أه إلى أي
درجة كانت أه مختلف
الجهات الحكومية قد تمكنت فعليًا من الوصول الكامل
إلى كل ما كان يجري على
تويتر أه أذهلني لم أكن أعلم
أن ذلك يشمل الرسائل المباشرة للأشخاص
أه نعم
نعم ، لأن السدود غير مشفرة ،
لذا فإن أول ما تعرفه هو أحد
الأشياء التي نحن بصدد إصدارها هو
القدرة على تشفير DM الخاص بك ، وهو
واجب ثقيل للغاية على الرغم من أن الكثير من
المراسلين المعروفين يتحدثون إلى
مصادرهم الحكومية  المسؤولون ،
أغنى الناس في العالم ،
يتلاعبون ببعضهم البعض ومن
الواضح أن الافتراض كان
غير صحيح ، لكن كان هذا أمرًا خاصًا
ولكن هذا كان يتم قراءته من قبل
حكومات مختلفة ، نعم ، هذا أمر مخيف ،
نعم ، نحن نتحرك للحصول على
نظام إدارة الوجهات السياحية  أن تكون مشفرة اختياريًا ،
أعني أنك تعرف أن هناك الكثير من
محادثات DM التي تعرفها فقط
الدردشة مع الأصدقاء ، ليس
مهمًا ، ومن المأمول أن يظهر في
وقت لاحق من هذا الشهر ، ولكن في موعد لا يتجاوز
الشهر المقبل ، إذا كنت في
محادثة  تعتقد أنه حساس
يمكنك فقط تشغيل التشفير ومن ثم
لا يمكن لأي شخص في Twitter رؤية ما
تتحدث عنه
حسنًا